we had a nice time not too long ago you
came over to my house yes for dinner I
don't know this was like must have been
six months ago maybe about uh six months
ago it was a dinner that was put
together by our mutual friend John
Mulaney who's a wonderful comedian and
for some reason he said I want to put
together a dinner of a bunch of
comedians and we're gonna and then he he
said we're gonna have it at Conan's
house and Conan's gonna serve the meal
and I was like oh okay yeah good alright
sure yeah and you very graciously agreed
and got bullied into it yeah it was
really fun it was a great great group
incredible group it was us - Mulaney
Nick Kroll Fred Armisen Eugene Eugene
laughs baby of levy yes Martin Short and
Steve Martin yeah yeah it was nice it
was I felt I was in my own home and I
thought I had won a contest yes it was
really come on that was just like wow it
was the greatest night of my life well
wait you just said you had a child yeah
but don't tell anybody I said that no
doubt about it but point being I don't
know if you remember this moment but
there's a moment in the night when I've
always been curious about something I
know you know what I'm talking about
because we worked at SNL but Lorne
Michaels
smells fantastic and there's a thing
everyone who works there knows which is
if he's just been in the hallway or if
he's just been in the elevator or
something you can smell whatever the
smell is that he smells like yes
Beck Lorne was just here it's a second
this is a very pleasant but hard to
define scent correct so I've always
wondered what it was and at that dinner
I was like man there's never gonna be a
better time to ask a group of people
because they all know him everybody at
that table had worked for Loren yes so I
was you know asked like hey anybody know
what that thing Loren uses what is that
and Mulaney actually was the one who was
like oh I was curious about that too
I asked someone in his office it's a
deodorant made by Hermes and I went oh
that's so cool I wouldn't be so funny if
we all got it and then we also bailed
like Lauren and freaked everyone out and
we were all laugh together ha ha ha
right then moved on do you
yeah I don't remember me laughing but
everyone else is like yeah you were
stone-cold on it was probably just
eating yeah we could use this on a talk
show at any rate a few weeks later
Mulaney
text me and he goes you'll never guess
what I just did I got the Lauren
deodorant and I was like that's funny so
did I you got it too I also went and got
it and he was like oh that's so funny
my wife Anna has been making fun of me
because for the first week I was using
it without taking the plot to
see-through plastic cap off the top so
here's spraying himself and nothing was
coming it's a roll oh I roll one okay
yeah I was like ha ha ha you dummy
wait what plastic cap idiot you were
like I feel like I have to put so much
of it on to make it work
grinding plastic you're probably walking
around going smell anything oh so then
uh-huh a little while after that we were
like aha ok but now we both smell
wonderful and we smell like Lauren then
a while after that I was chatting with
someone who works with Lauren and I told
that story
mm-hmm and they were like oh that's
funny he doesn't use Hermes that's not
it
oh you're kidding and I was like what
and they're like yeah 100% that's not it
and I was crushed and I called John and
I was like hey man it's not the right
one we're not using the Lauren scent and
he was like what did who the hell do we
smell like and I said I think we smell
like each other
[Laughter]
but I'm still using it it turns out
Lauren uses those free things that come
in the magazine and just whatever I got
them all fooled there uh damn take a
snap
I am so yeah I'll do that yeah that's
the first thing I'll do recommending it
to the world
you